décision concernant l'opération
militaire c'est une qui s'exprime avec
ces ministres à Moscou de revoir les
lois
dans les différents domaines dans
l'économie d'une manière générale dans
les différents domaines et secteurs de
l'économie en ce qui concerne les forces
armées et les approvisionnements à
l'armée nous avons rencontré certaines
difficultés et nous avons senti la
nécessité de revoir un autre façon
d'organiser les choses
déjà pendant la pandémie
du covid
donc nous avons déjà pensé à revoir nos
procédures et notre base législative
pour
optimiser le fonctionnement de tout cela
et aujourd'hui nous avons rencontré la
nécessité de résoudre de manière plus
rapide
les différentes questions liées
aux approvisionnements de notre armée et
également nous avons rencontré des
difficultés économiques
aux différentes restrictions
et nous avons discuté avec plusieurs de
vous qui participeraient à cette réunion
de cette nécessité de revoir et
d'améliorer notre travail est
d'optimiser nos procédures
administratives
nous en avons parlé à plusieurs reprises
la situation est-elle aujourd'hui que
elle nous pousse à faire ce travail
et à s'y pencher de manière à encore
plus rapprochée et attentive aujourd'hui
donc nous voudrions aujourd'hui
mettre à plat toutes les procédures
administratives les revoir de fond en
comble
d'une manière très large toutes nos
procédures de gouvernance
évidemment pour cela nous avons besoin
d'une coordination très large et très
profonde entre les différentes
institutions ministères de tous les
domaines ça concerne les forces de
maintien de l'ordre cela concerne les
domaines économiques
c'est pour cela que nous avons créé le
conseil de coordination je voudrais vous
rappeler
que le Conseil de coordination
a été chargée de
mettre en place les
différentes
demandes les spécifications qui sont
nécessaires dans les différents domaines
je voudrais rappeler que nous avons des
représentants de l'administration des
régions de la Fédération de Russie dans
ce conseil nous avons nommé à la tête de
ce conseil de coordination au le
président du gouvernement le Premier
ministre et je voudrais lui parler
la parole
pour que monsieur michostine nous parle
justement de la façon dont ce travail
sera organisé et des priorités
je vous en prie Michael
je vous remercie cher collègue
nous avons donc créé à la demande du
Président ce conseil de coordination qui
a eu sa première réunion hier nous avons
tout d'abord établi sa structure et ses
tâches principales ont confiant ces
tâche
au vice-Premier ministre notamment
monsieur
grégorynco et en ce qui concerne les
approvisionnements militaires et les
ravitaillements ce sera monsieur
mantourov qui en sera chargé messieurs
Montereau sera chargé également du
groupe de travail deux autres vis
Premier ministre vont être à la tête
des différents groupes de travail
monsieur rousseline qui sera chargé de
l'infrastructure des casernes de base de
formation les questions de transport et
de logistique madame golikova ce que
fera des questions médicales et
notamment
de l'aide spécialisée et de l'aide de
technologie kabilisation de nos
militaires et évidemment il va aussi
s'occuper une des questions des
paiements aux militaires nous avons les
différentes actes axes pardon de travail
très important l'énergie la
communication
les systèmes informatiques
ici et également le lien avec les
familles des personnes mobilisées
nous avons déjà une haute-lagne hotline
où les personnes peuvent appeler pour
obtenir des informations spécifiques
en virgule 5 millions d'appels déjà ont
été adressés à ce centre d'appel
maintenant il y en a en peu moins 20
milles par jour et c'est une base de
données véritable avec des questions et
des réponses nous avons un portail
spécifique
qui permet de visiter ce portail et
obtenir
ces réponses il y a eu déjà 18 millions
de connexions à ce portail
nous avons également
un autre
domaine un secteur pacifique dans le
portail unique des services publics qui
est consacré également à ces questions
Vladimir Vladimir
de rapporter
sur les formations
et le support à nos militaires
mobilisés c'est Madame golikova et
Monsieur
cellulos qui rapporte
sans 95 ça c'est les paiements qui sont
octroyés à chaque militaire et le
ministère de la Défense qui s'en occupe
directement nous faisons le suivi
très rapproché pour voir comment
ces sommes sont payés en effet
et nous avons préparé
un forum qui fera en retour sur la mise
en oeuvre de ces mesures également il y
a des mesures d'aide au niveau
régional et pas seulement fédéral et
nous sommes sûrs que ce conseil de
coordination permettra d'assurer une
meilleure connection à tout le niveau
pour reprendre à tous les besoins de nos
militaires je voudrais parler
spécifiquement des moyens de protection
individuelle
il faut augmenter la production de ces
moyens pour pouvoir assurer
l'approvisionnement
en ces équipements de nos militaires il
faut que tout toutes les sociétés toutes
les entreprises dans les régions
travaillent pour
que nos militaires ne manquent de rien
le ministère de la Défense a chargé a
été chargé de développer les
spécifications pour ces équipements on
va octroyer de l'argent supplémentaire
pour
approvisionner tous les équipements
nécessaires à notre armée
Vladimir vladimirovic le conseil de
coordination fera de réunions régulières
et on vous rapportera de nos décisions
toutes les semaines comme cela a été
demandé merci
monsieur sebani à vous la parole
bonjour cher Vladimir Vladimir cher
collègue comme vous l'avez demandé nous
avons créé un groupe de travail du
Conseil d'État tout les toutes les
entités de la Fédération de Russie et
les représentants de services spéciaux
sont représentés nous avons quatre axes
de travail pour mieux sont les décrets
du président
concernant les niveaux de réaction sur
les menaces détectées
c'est un domaine assez complexe
technique
nous y travaillons les différentes
ministères de maintien de l'ordre sont
représentés
ce travail avant de manière
normale sans mesures extrêmes mais dans
certains territoires comme à Belgorod
par exemple dans la région de Belgorod
nous avons besoin de mesures
supplémentaires de réaction une somme en
train d'y travailler
deuxième axe de travail comme vous avez
demandé avec le soutien du mystère de la
défense déployée des mesures de
formation pour les personnes qui ont été
appelés et avec les différentes entités
de la Fédération de Russie nous avons
mis en oeuvre
en emplacement pour
les appeler qui ont été mobilisés
avec le ministère de la Défense nous
coordinons nos efforts
nous avons également
travaillé
sur les approvisionnements nécessaires
à ces personnes mobilisées il faut que
le travail soit plus efficace et nous
nous y appelons troisième axe de travail
le soutien social aux familles des
personnes mobilisant
c'est une aide aux financière
psychologique c'est aide aux enfants
aux familles des militaires si
nécessaire
c'est une aide à trouver des emplois et
des formations pour les épouses des
hommes mobilisés
ce sont également de mesures d'aide aux
enfants et à la garde des enfants
également les aides financières aux
familles qui ont des enfants nous allons
rendre ce travail plus systémique
et la plupart des entités
administratives de la Fédération de
Russie ont déjà mis en œuvre ses mesures
et le quatrième axe de travail qui est
déjà été mentionné ce sont des actions
pour se tenir notre complexe de défense
et
d'industrie afin de permettre de
produire tout dont a besoin notre armée
et certains
territoires et entités de la Fédération
de Russie sont en train de mettre en
place ces mesures également
merci beaucoup